[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm Christopher Hine and today we're
talking about aikido forms so what is a
form a form is a collection of
techniques in Aikido we unfortunately
tend to confuse a form and a technique
and we think they're the same thing but
a technique is an individual piece that
you might need to use in conflict
whereas a form is a strategic or
tactical collection of techniques that
are answering a specific set of problems
that's arising for a person unlikely
that you'll ever use a full proper
Aikido form I've done a lot of sparring
with Aikido I've maybe done an actual
form in sparring on maybe two or three
times not very often
however I've used the techniques of iq2
in sparring tons of times and the reason
is because the techniques that you find
in Aikido are the basic techniques that
you find in any other martial art that's
dealing with the same context that
Aikido is dealing with iqs dealing with
the context where someone has something
in their hand and they're trying to use
that something in their hand and this is
why there's all these wrist grabs
because there's something in their hand
and there's all these like big strikes
because there's something in the hand
right so I'm gonna get Josh out here and
we're gonna talk today about shomenuchi
ikkyo multi Lassa and we're gonna break
down all the little techniques that are
inside that form let's go to work Josh
all right
so we're talking about how forms are
collections of techniques and not
techniques themselves so when we talk
about a form so let's talk about the
form of shomenuchi ikkyo multi right so
here's the form so we're in this
position here I Drive Josh back I
capture the elbow that's the ego ient in
you to driving forward here and I pin so
that whole thing is is shomenuchi ikkyo
almost a Wazza and that's the whole form
now that is not a technique that's a
collection of techniques so that form is
a collection of techniques so that's a
collection techniques and I'm gonna talk
you through that collection techniques
as we go so the first part is the
shomenuchi this alright now this is a
little more than the video is going to
get into I just want to
why that exists because that made me
look silly to people to go like this but
understand if I had a weapon and I
wanted to attack Josh I would stab him
like this and that's probably what he
would do is bring his arms up even if he
doesn't do that in a grand way right
let's say Joshua's gonna stab me with a
knife and I went ah right okay this is
normal oh I'm freaking out about stuff
if you look at police reports you'll see
that victims of stabbings often have
wounds all along the outside of the arm
here and that's because they're doing
just this they're trying to keep that
knife from stabbing them that is the
shomenuchi position so it's a natural
defensive position that comes from
someone trying to hit you with something
overhead and a knife is a likely reason
that someone would do that could also be
a stick coming down or whatever right
it's not an unarmed strike right it's
unlikely that someone's gonna go bulk on
top of the head like that right but if
they have a knife in their hand this is
totally a reasonable thrust net right
you see how quick Josh's arm jerk seems
like I don't like that all right so
that's the first part is just understand
this position exists so that's the first
technique we're learning in this born
the second technique is eqo which is
basically elbow control so I come under
the elbow here and I'm moving to mom now
if that technique was successful so the
first thing that you see so it would
look like this and that's shomenuchi
ikkyo mom thing it does not have to
continue into the pin or anything else
right so really simple the the next part
of this our second technique in this is
simply getting under that elbow and
driving them off now why would this be a
valuable technique well let's look at
the modern approach first right the
modern approach is this guy tried to
stab me with a knife okay I am armed
otherwise I Drive this guy off of me I
get to my my weapon and I'm out and on
target
right so that's why that little bit of
space would saved my life so that's
super useful for modern law enforcement
super useful and military situations
super useful for the civilian defending
themselves at a high level right so
that's a super useful thing to do that
techniques useful to be able to drive
them off real quick get to your weapon
and then use your weapon also
classically the same thing right so if
I'm a samurai and this samurais cutting
down and I go like this coming under
here drawing my sword and quickly
cutting across that's exactly how it
would have been used back in the day so
that's what that techniques for it's to
drive someone off so I can get to my
weapon platform or make an escape so
talking about a modern unarmed civilian
and people say like oh you know I'm not
armed all the time did if you're not
armed you should just get out of that
situation so if I Drive this guy away I
want to get out of the situation that's
my goal so there's our second technique
alright what's a third technique a third
technique in this is the takedown so
after I've gone here if for some reason
I need to take him down we're learning a
series of techniques to break this guy's
balance now why would that happen all
right let's say he's armed and he comes
down like this and I think well if I
just shoved this guy off and I don't
have a superior weapon he might be able
to come back at me let's say it's a
pretty strong guy and it can get a
little shoved like this but he's still
right there right so it's not gonna
settle things for me I maybe need to
drive into this guy and get a little
better weapon control or if my kids over
there and my wife's over there so here's
a smallish guy and I think I can handle
him my wife and kid are over there I
don't want to shove this guy over to my
wife and gear then he stabs them up and
I still go so I want to deal with this
guy so I need to know a way to control
this guy from weapon arm position right
so here I have the left arm control and
I can break him down and there's a way
to break them down from here right so
it's simply pull to the side where he
doesn't have it on here like this
hopefully that would break his bounces
hand jumps over there I Drive them back
the other way and so that's the
technique we learned to get the takedown
from this why is that takedown that way
well because if I want to take this guy
down and go for his legs you can see
that's a real bad option for me right if
I want to go into some kind of upper
body clinch
even if actually sweet guys switch to
the other side for me just so people can
see this really easy so let's say I go
into some kind of body clinch right here
it's still getting cut up right so when
I do the takedown for this you have to
have weapon on control so that's what it
teaches us so that's our next technique
in this series teaching its weapon arm
control so we're here like this alright
now how else might that happen let's say
he's not armed but I'm armed
okay so I've got a weapon this guy just
broke into my house and I need to attack
this guy and he comes over the top now
as I go to shove him away he gets a grip
on my weapon hand so I'm trying to shove
this guy off trying to shove this guy
off and he's got to hold my weapon hand
so I can't use my weapon
he's right here what am I gonna do I'm
gonna try and break and yeah
in that same way now from here whether
he's armed or I'm armed we got to get
this weapon clear either I'm clearing my
own weapon or disarming him so if I'm
armed what am I gonna do them and put
pressure into this so I can get my
weapon free what does this look like
well it looks like a lot of the
techniques you say you and she been
doing except he doesn't often have a
knife in his hand he's going like this
what do you think this represents well
maybe this right so from this position
I'm trying to clear my my weapon hand
what if he had the weapon well what am I
doing here I'm trying to drive that
weapon out of his hand so I can take it
away from him so there's our fourth
technique I'm trying to take it away now
if I needed to hang out with this guy
for a while right so we've got some
serious issues I need to hang out with
this guy I'm gonna drop my knee here I'm
going to continue into the pin and I'm
gonna try and get control the situation
now that is at the end of this form
which means it's the least likely
technique we want to do now the problem
is when people see this stuff they go
the whole objective of that technique
which is actually a form is to pin the
guy it's not true it's simply one
technique in a progression and if you
look at it it's the one that's failed
the most right they jump so when we look
at techniques what we need to be able to
do is aren't when we look at form see
now I'm doing it when we look at forms
we need to be able to understand that a
form is a collection of techniques and
not just one huge technique so when
you're trying to perform one huge
technique it's really hard to understand
all the bits in there and to tactically
understand what Aikido suggesting the
forms are the absolute least important
thing that we could do and the
techniques are a little more important
but the techniques extend to making
distance and all kinds of other things
which are actually better ideas but when
we get down into it when you'd
understand with all these individual
pieces so I'm Christopher hind this is a
breakdown of shomenuchi ikkyo or what
there was
[Music]